là on se connaît depuis longtemps avec
isabelle c'est vrai oued oum indiqué non
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis super content d'être là avec
nous ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bienvenue dans la roulotte de
nada nisa alors si vous regardez c'est
que vous êtes dépressif ou au chômage
vous les donne alors j'en profite pour
saluer tous nous téléspectateurs bernard
martin éric et c'est tout l'inversé le
maire des badauds ont fait défaut
récurrent à huy est la dernière de jésus
était en arrière
jeff à la clotte matthieu delormeau
venez me rejoindre pour ce bras de fer
à ma droite la droite le champion mi
mousses m'immole de 82 ans vainqueur par
ko deroff en mai dernier d'un sur des
fûts nrj12 je vous le rappelle
à ma gauche le champion du développé
couché sur 9 ans ni son pipi radioactifs
je vous le rappelle ils aiment le blanc
d'oeuf et le filet
c'est mon cousin qu'il faut pas faire
chier sinon fin c'est le cousin jean
marc il faut pas faire puisque ce soit
ce soir on avec nous en exclusivité pour
le bras de fer contre mathieu delormeau
lambeaux big
[Applaudissements]
mathieu fait l'amour ce week-end il
s'appelle alex
et toi et trois week-ends à moi j'ai
[ __ ] aussi
[Applaudissements]
m
tara johns un agent tony que les
philosophes oriente les salles excite
mon travail c'est de comprendre et de
soigner les bouffées de chaleur les
reflux gastrique générés par un air vo
vite et en tractant sur le larynx à
cause d'une dilatation des muqueuses et
les corps spongieux faiblarde
on se connaît depuis longtemps avec
isabelle c'est vrai à oued ou indiqué
non mais qu'est ce qui te plaît plus
autour de la table géraldine ah ouais
pourquoi c'est ce que j'adore quand et
d'idées nous savons à winneway jury
fluide en faut un déclic
voilà et tu sais qui pourrait donner des
conseils sur les meufs les battre on
allait resserrer dans mon sac pour lui
donner mais calme et peut-être de
s'épiler un peu parce que là c'est la
mode et plus tellement
[Musique]
alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]